you know you're driving the same car
since high school you're driving your
car into a ground so for you
having a car isn't a nice car isn't that
important you just are you more of an a
to b type of girl like i gotta get
around i'm not gonna drive a piece of
[ __ ] as long as it gets me to point to
point b okay i'm not gonna drive like a
yeah okay now flip side that's for you
how important it is for your man to
drive a nice car
for your man to drive a nice car how
important is that
it is i mean i
hope it's not like a
a rape van
yeah
pretty much hey kids come on into the
room
for me it's the memories we make in them
oh my god this girl is
okay so it's not that but there's a
limit to the car right of course what's
the limit this is what i'm trying to get
like he doesn't have to drive a mercedes
but you were pretty clear like toyota
camrys if your dude wrote up in a toyota
camera you'd be okay with that oh i'd be
chilling how about a toyota corolla
cool toyota corolla yeah
if it's not like if it's nice it's not
run down like as long as it's not a
rundown car
okay but you are you are pretty clear
jenny that if your dude has got a mini
cooper that it's not a good i just mean
like because i feel like a mini cooper's
a more feminine car like i just like if
you're i don't feel like it's like
masculine for you to pull up in my car
in my little mini cooper so is
[Laughter]
guys cars turn on turn off is there a
guy is that something that he can drive
and you're like dude just a guy just
rolled up on a porch and i'm turned on
right now or it's like buddy just rolled
up and uh broke down civic what are your
limits with a car so i grew up with a
lot of asians and we have what they call
ricers
racers like a racer but like an asian
rice eraser sure but it's like a tokyo
dress style like lowered honda accord
lots of led lights the thing on the back
what's that thing called spoilers
spoilers like three feet spoilers and
stuff yeah asians this is what they do
your crew
sure
sure you i mean there's a category
something that do it and then at some
point you get kind of like burnt out on
it so then like growing up with guys
that were like so obsessed with their
cars yeah
and then spinning everything they did
just to like soup up like their little
honda fit or whatever okay so
i think after a certain point you kind
of outgrow that because that was during
the time where like fast and furious was
like super crazy and then everybody
wanted to like do street racing and
everything
so as long as they're not that
obsessed with it
that has no like unless they're being
like a professional racer or something
then so you're more concerned about the
obsessiveness of the car yeah you're
like dude just get to a to b like i
don't need you to you know get the
system and the spoiler and the leds and
we're racing and what are you doing
yeah it's like focus on me make me happy
not your car happy
yeah you want him revving your engines
not the car engine did i do something
okay there was that right yeah yeah sure
jenny
okay
so if a dude rolls up in a sick car
give me a sick car we like dude that's a
sick car what's a sick car to you sick
i mean if he shows up in a ferrari
that's cool ferrari okay
ferrari lamborghini you know
sick rolls royce what does that do to
you as a female like you're like oh [ __ ]
okay okay like are you more willing to
like
you know put out a little bit you know
what i'm saying what does a car do sick
car
don't say nothing don't say it
don't give me the it just it matters the
memories that happened
it's just it's just
like growing up in miami is a different
whole vibe of this you know what i mean
so i feel like when you're younger and
you don't really understand life
and you're just like looking at it like
oh wow that's a nice car like wow but
when you grow up and you see the
logistics of what's really happening
it's it changes perspective like a lot
of men think that they can buy you just
by pulling up in a nice whip yeah which
you don't even own you just rented it to
take me out on this date which i
appreciate
you investing in the state
however
i want the like i want the real you like
i don't want you to think that you can
just buy me oh you're saying that they
rent a car for the dates some guys do
that oh it's like your high school
reunion but that's why when you talk
yeah but what do you want some guys do
that i'm gonna need a car for this
weekend as my high school union yeah
some guys do that and it's well miami is
the king of i rent a lamborghini for the
weekend
being in miami is a different you know i
did like what you say it's not about the
cards the memories that we make in the
car but it is front seat or back seat
all seats
tell me what about if he comes in a bike
who's that oh if he comes in a bike
someone basically can't wait is there
room
can we just have a regular voice if
you're gonna weigh in i feel like the
voice of god over here so
okay so if a guy drives an absolute
clunker piece of [ __ ] are you giving him
a second date i'm a little turned off
i'm not gonna turn it off so if a
clunker rolls up and he's like hey get
in it's like my parents used honda civic
it's kind of broke you're turned off
is that you're turned off if it's a
piece of [ __ ] one of the racers show up
and it's like the worst racer out there
it's
you know sparks
so
because like what's the limits for like
how big of a piece of [ __ ] like if it's
like a jalopy so from what i heard like
when it comes to money you should
definitely invest in uh anything that
keeps you off the ground so your shoes
your bed and like your wheels and your
car
say that again anything you should
invest in what now like if you're gonna
like ball out on something it should be
something that keeps you off the ground
so like you need good shoes you need to
protect your feet you need a good bed to
like it's good for your back yeah and
then you need good wheels for your car
because if you can't drive from a to b
that's the whole you lose
everything yeah specifically you're
focused on the wheels not the actual
vehicle yeah but if you're not committed
to the rest of the car the wheels are
probably dog [ __ ] too oh i like that i
like that what happens if like uh i
think was calvin that just chimed in he
said what happens if he rolls up on a
bike
what's up hop in the [ __ ] in the back
baby
what is it like are we going on a picnic
like i'm kind of down for that
you know it's a picnic what about a
motorcycle
guys that drive motorcycles is that a
turn on or is that a little dangerous
motorcycles are cool yeah nervous okay
nervous i've only been on a motorcycle
once and i enjoyed it but it's no it's a
vacuum what happens if there was like
this dude right hypothetical i'm just
gonna make this up on top of my head
guy's doing pretty well for himself
pretty successful lives in a sick place
right he's got money he's doing his
thing he might even host his own show
but then he's got no car he just ubers
everywhere everywhere he doesn't have a
car he's just ubering everywhere what
are your thoughts on that
i would ask him what his reasoning is
for it yeah i'll tell you why my
reasoning is my reasoning
okay so you know i live downtown miami
i'm talking about myself
i live downtown miami northern miami
heat arena is right there
okay i live right there you know where
the marquee is or whatever yeah you know
where the um the museum is yeah okay so
i worked that's where i lived
and i was driving up to boca nonstop and
my older mercedes
it broke down i was like all right let
me see
it was gonna cost like three grand to
like fix this mercedes i was just over
it i was like i'm not gonna fix it let
me see how long i could go with no car
10 years later i still have no car i
uber everywhere jenny but where i live
downtown miami the only place i'm going
is around downtown miami or to south
beach and if i'm going to south beach
i'm going to have a drink i'm going to
party i'm an uber i'm not trying to
catch a dewey a lot of my friends have
caught duis so i've avoided that
so it has not stopped me from having a
good time dating all that kind of good
stuff i've actually even bought a
girlfriend a car i just don't want to
have a car yeah is there a problem with
that
no good answer
well that's the thing like sometimes
nancy gives me a ride home occasionally
because i think it's implied if you
don't have a car you're broke yes and if
you're not broke then i it if it works
out for you then sure
i agree well here's here's here's what
i'm saying if you live in new york city
or in any major freaking city if you
don't have a car nobody thinks like
you're like nobody's not a big deal but
in miami for some reason people like you
don't have our car how do you get
groceries it's like have you ever heard
of instacart you've heard of amazon you
remembered any of this stuff yeah so
but the point that i'm getting at these
days let me try to you know clearly a
guy let me just state some facts right
now
guy rolls up with a piece of [ __ ] not a
good look guy rolls up with a mini
cooper probably not a masculine look
okay
supply and demand car prices are insane
right now car cars aren't exactly a good
investment to begin with so now if
you're typically paying 20 grand for a
car now you're paying 30 grand for a car
you're just getting yourself more into
debt now obviously with a car you got a
car loans you got interest rates you got
gas you got maintenance you got upkeep
god forbid you got a dui it's just a
bunch of nonsense if you're if you live
in a major city here's my point if you
live in a major city major city you live
in the downtown you can work from home
you can work from anywhere you're not
driving a half hour to work any day the
average car sits sits 95 percent of the
day that's 23 out of 24 hours my point
to you is this flip the script people
you don't have to have a car especially
if you're going to go into debt or broke
for your car
and if you can somehow get around
without a car give it a shot i've done
it for 10 years
you